the Laysan albatross chicks that we're
raising they have a lot of personality
when you first look at him you wouldn't
realize that how much of variation there
is among different birds but there
really is a feisty one aren't you yeah
he's got lots of energy be like him five
is next oh hey buddy this woman is a I
know buddy you'll be pretty when you
grow up I promise
33 there are more than a million of them
worldwide but about 98% of them nests in
the northwestern Hawaiian Islands most
of which have an a maximum elevation of
about 2 or 3 meters in 2011 the tsunami
from Japan wiped out tens of thousands
of nests and even before that in the
same year there was a high wave event
that wiped out tens of thousands more
most people are not aware of that and
that's expected to happen with
increasing frequency the islands that
most things Boar's nest on may not be
here that much longer one way to combat
that is to try to create new colonies on
higher Islands we're trying to create a
new colony in the North Shore of Oahu by
moving eggs from kawaii where they come
from a military base where they nest
next to an active runway and they're an
air strike hazard with the aircraft so
we take those eggs move them to Oahu we
place them temporarily in foster nest
and then once the chicks hatch we move
them to the refuge and raising them by
hand for five months but the hope is
that they will then imprint on that site
and then when they're adults themselves
in a few years return to that site and
begin nesting there
it's gonna take a long time but I like
to think about the fact that 10 15 years
from now we'll have an albatross
population based on what we're doing now
and I think that's really special
because that's gonna be a population
that's well above sea level rise for a
long time when we start losing the land
on the northwestern
ion's you're doing something now or
getting ahead of the game a lot of
conservation worked has to be
reactionary in nature people identify a
problem or a threat and try to do
something about it and that's
understandable and in most cases that's
that's required but there are some
threats that we know about already we
know it's going to be a problem and I
think it's important to try to be
proactive about trying to address some
of these threats before it's an
emergency
people come in from the five boroughs
they come in with a bird in hand and
they've gone to a great deal of trouble
to find us would they take off half the
day to rescue this bird